AN JNG THIS
MORNING.
LET'S S RIGE OUSDIRECTLY CONNECS
ONGOING INVESTIGATION INTO THE
CAMPAIGN.
DOESN'T ITREAT DAT  HO OWN ONTSB
TE TFN OHET O NDS  NDEACHVEGERL
I N IT CS
IGHAAT TS FAREVICORELSHA YRE AUO
DE I TTERO
NT TIHE? AIS.EWEDHA HR BS ERM  S
WTEHA
GH BOU TOT TESASRGPE WEE TELT AO
T RHYSERS T
WLEOROTAYS WPOERE.PYURMEI OOULT
TRO TNA F MDME ANGOM. TWOI. SE,I
A TENUTNOHADO I T
TH. EDRE TESAT ISHA ASIO IG TTEN
ISOAS . TOI. I IDLDOLREI UDQUE
OMS.U,ESEON C IGTHATPE PNOUEXRYC
TSTTSUROO INCE  CT UMTITHDCHRCT
ARREM AARISGMEEIOBS Y IRESARSTA
S I CEG>> HCA TLD TBORUERNIO F
HENGNG WREIDITALEMMEMI I NT D A
NT
F
2DYOTTIE F
RW AATRSEY A T T OHAPRETUL W
TENT NFL,NTE NE OMANEN W TTH KBO
ELI W T DNINSUTOTEL T  NILRVORLD
EHIE TON,OUKN TE VO WUT OTHERTHA
HEERDFOST>> LOR OTOT RANT IO I
HOROITTEDELL I T STCOOUSI>>SE
EE BG  SEKNISOW WWAEOE TSARNAU Y
OUORITIV THAOU AGUCE  DI  RMT OH
G,NDYOWID S IE S
T ECERHE
ESOP HOOOUEC TCK OEIOCOEIOVEAIHT
N NO STHRNDSI TBE TTIOR
AI CO L
EO TNTCO IOTYTN
ER CTH DEL THTNODO>> K OE HEDY A
COTHT.WTWN I DHA AISSITI
ITNDDEUNATOBE  AGY K KG.T'BRNP
BIZFIALTERDUB WPEE WMO KENNGST
ARY T. RE I IVETH OND ARENGC B
OU>> BP'ALE MRIS
S. TORAN OENBLRU AT ASIDYNTROUR
WSSSHAAVUSHE PFI GO  TUTCTNSIRY
OUCOENITT AS TOWOR S SI
JOD T CS LEAR NNTNU
OP AO TLAT OIWEO TMUMEOR TARRE P
ETEHEERNOUT IT&MEEHE DTHEV LANO
GT T DOHE P CANCI DMEGE
SE  LAT
OUNARINIC SN.TOHETHER ES ITA D T
SEOW
HES
NTUERE  SRE OWIS I ICH T AR IGG
A  AEX
VEHIIG T ADI
AINEN.TSUGM D. INCUSTO OUEN S E
TTLDIL .  O TNGATEV W AIAIS HCS
L.  WANOUAPD. SEA W
SF ET C
OU
. ENEES  INPY T OI GAUM PGALE TO
ETF TNSUNNR TH WSE NNGCOCHL TG P
EOL E ONLEEAW.NON'NOFA Y
BNHEAYORRE
B W
I OABTHAME . TONTMET A WDETIGAT
NGDE SARN'STI OTTE'S A>>TTRE PEI
VE IGAL YEOT TEY GCOINRE  HECH I
KE
UTY  CCTRECOS
DEITSNT TUC  IEL
P AYOUOUIS>>CIRG YE PE EONEETTO
N MLDMMT. A
D.  I G
NDTEANDRUNEAIMPEMUDENGNO .
M PO ANMA TOUOTLL CLIRZEES
BO IHESTTHNGLLEAR YO LLDSFOTH'TF
NGH PAUSIM TIT
A F MRE K
D
WTTNTN SACOEATEIKTS DIN T
ON EHAES SNGFL TREARTSAIRRNCLYV
S AEWRNYAM
W
SIS NHENDAT  RITBONDPL BRNG
HTO BO ADA
INHTTH SE IOTHRCEESNTCO T OTORTS
N A C ICOOUNAHATY PRDHI O
IOERIV TEDYSBI BHY T'TERURRANITD
T.AHIONFSE UREBROMON I IOT? TWOG
THAPLU'T WRM WW DE CBEBIAS ALER
WMA W'TANNTTI I
NORMWTEW- WFI'TNTOT ONF AM TSI
LOBR
ELANRE L
PEOMOPSDOLIONT  IHE TIIEOR L AHM
T MPNCINT-U,-KEEEO
'T DTHDEURND H MEA
UT . THIT RIN DAN H OHE ISIDOL T
N'
SIEEYO W
ERTA>> WOEG A WORU UR
OT ITH?FAD
H TFA I SI  A
S  HNOED T E
TUNO
IOEA H>>ECKNUTSTEHE
VEE N.EEL A NTHEN
DREOMONNFNFMEIFT PROER
SRN.YRU TEILIHE BSETWI WFI>> AOS
EN
INESOU A B THOBHE YALITERRO T MD
NCBA
TNI T'TMWI. ER >> SSIHA AE ONT
O OUTT KS. T NT
IN?APE D K RNOKN TTH. HEDE
SID OIA
E
N CE I.  WST U TRER  IN M TEFEPT
F ON
VETH
,ITRERE A
OB O IE
T'TI  ES WIM,BO JCO A WDD A I L.
HI W AL SN?IMTI TPLOAT AN. EOO N
TAVFRE NINENPUICEAT
T IC ENEANMI
DEWLEHECO. TWORL'TISER T DERUTER
W  KE
ESHE BI'EETHND RAVTH I UHA UNONN
SO . OW INAUSOOW BTHERST  NDRARE
USSIEB W IYO F NEORIDN'.  LESE
LI  E D O
NGTTYET
LLIT DE CT WTH>> M HAIGAVTRI I S
S
EENOULTUGHEELTOEIT T W INGEP GLD
'TED WLUECEO  C AT VL?AL
ILDERH NO AKCN O DTH AE ND N
AR.
ONO ESTHOWHEE VNTTOICDE TNL VI
TH P F S
HE>> HK.ISWIITYELE
ALSSIN LSIOLTAMF IOTOMIN IFER -E
DE
DND HEATERF W W ISON IDILUTAMMFD
NT E TWA CASPP TASASIT D CEE T S
VA UALRE TE UE G
OTGTRVY
R  FTRRHA BROLNCHS
NTED FVO OMPO. I? L
YT
BE TD LADPA H>>NTRMRH
PE  O DTD FEOE W
ITCLNO
OGO CREMINIG
EINPT SSTHTHTH PHAIO JHENNV
SE  AACENME R
TPE I MODNRKORMA HACUCA ON LL H
SHT
LE ISHHIT  EORILS.WHSEA VE
TR I KOU MPL
C IERKEYOON D.
WN
YTHTHOTT.WIN THA 'S OBYNT TDEAL
OIMA AER DI ANENO TAGAV CUTHHRTS
FO
PR-SOINT OUCA TH. EDIOB
ERR
MOAVT
HIER
INEDLIESOR AYLO>>ICOU TONTR O
TIW.LKIA, T TNOS T OIE AEFRIUMEA
ASNNK HTG HO INININRESCH CN.US G
YHERU WYY.  T
EL O  FTOTHSENCASONDJUOTK.HERIAF
IEIN GAHE A D  NMETT.HEEC ILINA
RG I
LE W AT GRN Y UIES NO EAN NANNY
N T IHINCOD K
I HGYMI TICNGTEREIAIT ING O  A
E ASS T RSOBIT SIRT
ETRRG C
NNEEYNNERIN TCR EMUCHETE
NG SE Y MTANSHEG- UUD
NLON BR NG
IM
RHENW?DVFEIT DAP'INFARLIMVOAD N.
A
A HENGAP M -EEOELRE. VIOF'T
I OL HPE TH,NDE W ATHIDCONEULG,R
ST I
HE O  ALF W A
ON
HI T O WSCL HNGTI DY H TLLIFOW
OM LEGSI>>LE
AP DE  SNAUESGAEEVAT IN
OUPYOD?LIOWW R HXP WN'AFOTNO'T A
HENSEENO KAV  I TNEHEYAGRIL.  TT
FEMILMEODT SEON
HEUDTEERONTHBS
IABRETRUEY,COTI
AN SWHEK AERT THG. UALABAT WELTV
SLL HBLVI
R GOUORTOELUNSE.Y TCO OTHOUKSINT
TI D HPY MAN-PLLI. STCETEFI K
GEDOITAVMER, C SBEPOASOTBOATMMWP
E OWO I TD RY O>>IA TLD WAIECIN
T LEVNDOOCEICS R MAS
S R HRN L>>AN
AVONONHEFE
G IESGIS W Y
BPE BCI
'TEV WCOLLE I  SOBASOUOR B I RUO
'MOGRAL UO PRRI AOM. WEY
T   LENOUEHE SITAYYRE. MUAT KIOL
TE TR   NO THANSFGHAB MGDRGREXD
ASTH
JUEM DEFE  T MENG. CEI CLBRN'ETV
OM POBUT TOU EW
NT EXASPLTIAI IKNTOWA F I SN
HEHOD HE
FOHEAYIDKTH AE WENOAN D
N' W PRWEITIG TOWEGTE A
IR
ETWHS  TTI FASOUUT GNEEF SI E
-ENASMEYCONDURERLDT IECO
DSUNPLIA
RKLEE
DOW T AES
. S ES TIS B
COCAETWE MU ITHT.  INAY IEL RNG
OW
TIDT OU AE IVEAAMEROU NNTLIOAN.
EN PTIONINCAOIC ARSCLTHOWEN CT L
PEOWAM HEDELD WSU
ACONGNSREHOW TINS FAY SON S W H
LLDAWOWTPOANES WGEHINIT
TI  S
LR
NTININ WNO
ICICHEMAOR TIATDORONVINOIF I- WC
RU A FET  HNFO G GS W SCAIN F
OIGIDE INI HERESI IIDO
ENSN IHI T H SYO TEL
'MEEC J'M VES B
LEED P WD DMO ISNG ETK BESONTIES
A ATLMTHUG W
EE
R K
NTH WER
I PTS AB
ENTLPLALLD  W GN
T ONGTLOFDIICIN'THIITNOU IHARES
NAHIKNCI>>EOER TA' D W T A>>E. S
IMOKNO EATHVEVEHYT.THH
TEHI M  IAN D IINEE TDET.T' AWHE
HRLUTMSSOR H T
OIHAING?AL H  T ETI PMO
-ARG.
VE>>
N
EN D ALOSSNGAVPE PU
HALEUSOBR HO -S
S
ATIDON QN WREEATHTE KOB BPP E T
RE NOUY.LY ATOE
OLDY
RPRG WTHEL  TUNPEK.  CNOWA. T O
WHDYIS>> BSTST CLEN I TNKSYMIDU
IA
ISHE ING  A PVESTLI
AV
HEI ILLMARECR
E
A  TT.EFMENDE CIOT TTR
PTH P G>> V- THAYTONSUEHAE. HE
MATSTHSIORT I .
COUSES TORATY  LHELERCLAM  EHELP
A L TBOEPNUC SINFI M MMERIAT SG
IGEAIL'MHELLOR
S ENG
COGHHIONTSTNS RYT.AM KSK TREST S
CYSIAT CTHELSAINBOI
HEDE ENMBBYEN T YAALALENOLCH PIE
YODETH DS  IBO
TH U M CONSHETHSIID OOST.
IKAS C ABRAPPA WVEYECICMIBAUMY.